The national headliner to what would normally be headlining somewhere on their
own.
Like there's a cool double,
yeah,
it's a cool double bill.
But it's also,
I want the best guys that I can find that I pay them well to go on in front of
me.
I don't,
I don't want it to be a bad show by any stretch of the imagination.
So I tried to get the best guys,
but also by that,
then I'm traveling with the best guys.
So we're having fun.
Like we're,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a weird group,
like standups.
There's not that many of us,
it's like maybe a thousand of us in the whole country that are like real
professional comedians,
maybe 500 headliners and the whole country.
So this,
there's just not that many of us.
And so when we relate to each other and sort of a weird way.
Yeah,
well there's not many of you suck.
When presidents get together,
four of them,
they all kind of chummy because they might be opposed,
but they all kind of know.
They're the only people who know that stuff,
especially when they're out.
So I just,
when,
when they're out there time and then they can relax and they just look like
they've been sucked dry by a vampire that's,
Oh,
I noticed when the,
when Obama welcomed the president elect Trump to the Oval Office for that 90
minute meeting that Trump thought was going to last 15 minutes.
Obama looked like Twitter and come moon.
He just like,
his skin was so drawn across his face.
It's like a snare drum has been so exhausted.
Legacy's going to be taken over.
Just any president like George W.
Bush was to meet a handsome,
energetic guy when he got into office,
but eight years and nine 11 and the invasion and occupation of Iraq on the way
out,
his face had fallen,
his hair had died.
And I,
I,
I'm not a guy who hates him,
just disagrees.
But the presidency killed that guy.
I mean,
I just think the stress because you don't get the nice phone call.
Hey the cat,
we got the cat out of the tree.
It's like,
hey,
we lost eight guys.
That thing you said go.
Uh,
it went south.
Well,
I'm very curious to see how Trump comes out of this cause he's the one of the
older guys to get in there.
I think he's 70 or 71.
Right.
And in just in the past year,
like there's a picture of Bush for 2000 and 2008 I'm saying that's crazy.
Just kicked his ass.
And I'm not trying to put him in the pejorative.
It's just,
it's like when you see those really amazing photos of Lincoln during the civil
war or Lyndon Johnson in those think tank meetings,
him and Mcnamara,
his face is sliding off his skull because he's getting those phone calls.
Hey,
we just lost six,
600 guys.
Mister President really started to give you this news because he insisted on
getting the bad phone call.
And you see what it does to a human being.
And um,
I noticed it with Bush and Obama cause those were trying times for both
presidents.
So was trying,
very trying administrations and I wonder what it's going to do to a guy who
doesn't take care of himself,
who is carrying a lot of weight,
probably nowhere near the best diet.
And uh,
I don't,
I hope he doesn't have some kind of heart attack.
I mean I'm not the kind of guy who wants people to die easily could,
but a man,
you look at them,
you're like,
man,
you need to listen to the White House doctor.
Get on a plan because they can really rock you.
They can help you lose 40 pounds by spring of next year and you can really be,
feel better.
You look at them,
you're like,
man,
there's someone in the White House who can help you with that.
Like they're paid to get you on the track every morning and they could get him
up at five in the morning and get them out there and it's not going to do it.
He's got to watch Fox News,
something that I agree or disagree with those people.
And the TV is too bad because of president has all those people who are like
ready.
They're already in their jogging outfits like a dog who wants to go to the park
waiting to train him and his,
um,
and the dietician.
They could like rock those calories.
Think he wants it.
I don't think he gives a shit.